[Musique]
les essentielles du sénat
santé mentale l'urgence d'agir
encore tabou les troubles psychiques
concernent chaque année un français sur
cinq et leur prise en charge et le
premier poste de dépenses de l'assurance
maladie devant la prise en charge des
cancers
les besoins d'accompagnement en santé
mentale qui émerge des effets de la
crise sanitaire font peser une pression
supplémentaire sur un système déjà en
forte tension alerte les sénateurs
victoire jasmin les gens seuls auteurs
du rapport après le choc de la crise
sanitaire réinvestir la santé mentale
fait au nom de la commission des
affaires sociales
le rapport fait état d'une augmentation
de 23 % de nouveaux patients pour les
prescriptions d'antidépresseurs au cours
des premières vagues de l'épidémie en
2020 et 2021
les femmes les jeunes et les personnes
âgées sont les catégories identifiées
comme plus fragilisés
les soignants sont aussi concernés
ce contexte doit être saisie comme une
opportunité pour engager des évolutions
indispensables dans le champ de la santé
mentale estiment les auteurs du rapport
ils ont formulé 14 recommandations
visant à promouvoir l'organisation de
parcours de proximité lisible et
accessible
un premier levier d'action réside dans
la prévention et l'information
les auteurs du rapport suggèrent de
renouveler les pratiques en intégrant
des outils numériques qui permettent de
capter une demande de l'orienter de la
filtrer
par exemple les lignes des coûts tête
des personnes à franchir le pas pour
parler de leurs troubles psychiques voir
entrer dans un accompagnement
il est nécessaire que ces lignes
d'écouté puisse être adossé à un réseau
territorial de structure et de
professionnels à l'instar de ce que le
numéro vert psylle de france peut
proposer en s'appuyant sur l'expertisé
du centre psychiatrique d'orientation et
d'accueil du ghq de paris
parallèlement les rapporteurs
recommandent de renforcer la proche
intégrée de la santé mentale et la
coordination territoriale des acteurs
ainsi la diffusion des outils cliniques
permettant de repérer précocement des
troubles mentaux ou des souffrances
psychiques pourrait être étendu aux
pédiatres mais aussi auprès des acteurs
de la médecine du travail ou scolaire
ce besoin de coordination montre
également l'intérêt de promouvoir de
nouveaux métiers en santé facilitant
l'orientation des patients dans le
système de soins
les rapporteurs insistent notamment sur
le rôle des infirmiers de pratiques
avancées
enfin il apparaît indispensable de
renforcer le rôle des psychologues dans
le dispositif de soins
pour en savoir plus consultez la
synthèse du rapport
[Musique]